[Musique]
avez vous vu cette vidéo virale
en fait ça c'est une olive verte mais
qui était teintée en noir c'est juste
hallucinant on apprenait que les olives
vendus en conserve sous l'appellation
olives noires confite en france et
olives noires mur au canada était en
fait de jeunes olives vertes noires si
c'est un fruit qui était pas mûres on
vous fait croire qu'ils mureaux
colorants non ce n'était pas un scoop
une simple recherche suffit pour
constater que cette technique existe
depuis plus de 100 ans
voici frida iman surnommée la mère des
olives noires mur
cette américaine a inventé à la fin des
années 1800 en californie une technique
qui permet de modifier la couleur des
olives pour les mettre en conserve plus
rapidement les procédés californien dans
le fond c'est un fruit du hasard parce
que l'on faisait trempé d aller dans des
eaux qui avait naturellement des ions
ferreux et on s'est rendu compte que les
olives changer de couleur eric ayala ben
rubi escales et chimistes alimentaire il
faut penser que nos lives pour mûrir ça
prend plusieurs semaines de plus sur
l'arbre que nos livres qui avait alors
si on peut couper à ce niveau là on
cueille les allées vertes et si on peut
accélérer le noircissement mais c'est là
où les procédés californien est mis en
valeur
mais avant de parler du procédé la
spécialiste dans nos livres claudia
pharand tient à préciser ceci on ne peut
consommer aucune livre que soient vertes
mur ou très mûr on ne peut consommer
aucune aux livres frange pour la simple
raison que dans l'olive on a une
substance qui s'appelle le européenne et
cette substance là elle est très amer
donc on doit traiter toutes les olives
un mur très mûr pour la débarrasser de
cette amertume là donc on voit des âmes
et lisez les aux livres pour pouvoir les
rendre comestibles alors la première
étape quand on va transformer désolé
c'est les tremper dans une solution
alcaline ou un bain de soude pour
pouvoir détruire cette molécule à l'eau
les européennes qui elle est composée
trait à ma cette vidéo de l'association
californienne de l'olive mur nous
explique comment le lit verte vire au
noir
[Musique]
pas besoin d'attendre le mûrissement
dans l'arbre c'est l'oxygène qui noircit
la jeune olive
mais ce n'est pas tout on ajoute aussi
un ingrédient spécial les gluconate
ferreuse caisse à la fin ça va réagir
avec des composés phénoliques
naturellement présent dans le livre pour
produire ces firmes en noir qui va nous
permettre de stabiliser ou créer une
coloration noire uniforme et nos lives
peu noircir naturellement soit par
mûrissement sur l'avs soit par oxydation
on n'est pas obligé de mettre du bleu
connaître erreur par contre cette
couleur-là est moins stable et l'est
beaucoup moins prononcé que le noir est
obtenu par l'ajout et la réaction
d'oxydation avec le gluconate terrain
normalement c'est un livre là vont été
réalisés se dire misant cannes pour la
conservation
on a tenté l'expérience à la maison en
ajoutant du gluconate ferrua des olives
vertes
une semaine plus tard les olives ont
noirci
santé canada réglemente l'utilisation du
gluconate ferreux dans la transformation
de ces olives notre chimistes se fait
rassurant c'est sûr que si on mangeait
cette boîte d'olive par jour mais on
pourrait avoir un problème mais ça
serait plutôt le sel que les femmes
[Musique]
le livre noir style californienne ce
n'est pas une olive qui très apprécié
par les gourmets sa cause dans les
boîtes à pizza
pendant tout dans les restaurants sur
les pizzas
on les utilise aussi pour faire des caps
nahd des sauces
on a fait goûter une jeune olives vertes
une kalamata plus violacé et bien sûr
notre vedette du jour de livres noirs
mûrs
bien noir mais la batterie
son matelas
et d'où elles viennent sur va plus loin
de coûts wizz bout que ce goût vous
connaissez déjà mangé
oui un coup de fer
heureux ouais qu'est ce qui vous fait
dire ça
les animaux
[Musique]
comptabilisa minois en gamme
même pas des coûts
des livres vendus
ça le moigne bouche soumettre les deux
autres
la verte et l'avant-centre m ammann tous
ces tunnels
ce n'est pas vraiment une olive qui mur
si on veut se référer aux olives mais je
me réfère aide en cas d olives noires
faudrait se référer aux olives noires
qui ont mûri sur l'âme et qu'on ait fait
sécher au soleil
et puis qui ont vraiment un goulot
vraiment de d'olives noires alors que le
livre de celle californienne n'a pas le
goût de l'olive noire mûri naturellement
elle n'a pas le goût mais elle est quand
même meilleur marché